un encuentro para afianzar lazos los
presidentes de México Canadá y Estados
Unidos se reúnen durante la Cumbre de
los líderes de América del Norte para
discutir asuntos cruciales de la
relación trilateral como el desarrollo
de un gran plan Regional de apoyo a
países latinoamericanos presidente usted
tiene la llave
para abrir y mejorar sustancialmente las
relaciones entre todos los países del
continente americano
un tema ya abordado por Joe biden
durante su reciente visita a la frontera
con México además de su anuncio con el
cual permitirá que 30.000 migrantes de
Venezuela Nicaragua Cuba y Haití
ingresan legalmente a Estados Unidos
cada mes los funcionarios fronterizos
estadounidenses detuvieron un récord de
2.2 millones de personas en la frontera
con México en 2022 la lucha contra el
narcotráfico es otro tema en la agenda
especialmente el fentanilo esta droga
sintética que es responsable de miles de
muertes por sobredosis en Estados Unidos
cada año también discutimos nuestra
seguridad compartida incluida nuestra
acción conjunta para combatir la Plaga
de fentanilo que ha matado más de
100.000 personas hasta ahora México
Busca fondos para impulsar proyectos de
energía solar y explotación de litio en
medio de una controversia con Estados
Unidos y Canadá tras considerar que el
proyecto violaría el acuerdo libre
comercio temec entre los tres países
diversidad equidad inclusión y
competitividad con el resto del mundo
son otros temas de los cuales se esperan
anuncios al finalizar el encuentro la
última cumbre de Los tres amigos como se
les conoce informalmente se celebró en
noviembre del 2021 en Washington desde
entonces los tres países han visto
significativos cambios para fortalecer
su relación